did this happen here is that the
earthquake has brought down some
buildings others have been left standing
let's go and have we don't want to get
in The Rescuers way here let's just have
a bit of a look here what they've done
is brought in a couple of diggers they
are working on the remains of an
apartment building
I'm looking at
10 12 meters of of rubble of slabs of
concrete collapsed in on
themselves it's difficult to see how
anybody would survive
the collapse of a building like this
very very difficult but you know they're
going to try they're here they need help
clearly
and you've got people on the other side
of the street desperate for news I mean
absolutely desperate
there are
people women on the other side crying
as they look on